your business invigorates you your
conviction is stronger than ever before
when you aren't talking about your
business you're thinking about it while
you're eating showering driving and
sleeping you couldn't be more excited
and afraid and despite all of the
attention you give to your idea your
business your baby you struggle selling
and can't understand why perhaps you
don't have enough opportunities in your
pipeline maybe you have plenty of
opportunities but aren't closing enough
or any of them you work as social
networks but maybe the social networks
aren't working for you whatever it is
the revenue you had hope needed to
generate isn't keeping up with the money
you need to spend and live on so the
question is with your great business
idea and all the strong conviction why
is selling so difficult let's discuss
the top three reasons why entrepreneurs
struggle so much with selling and
determine whether or not there's
anything you can do about it number one
this is different let's compare the
difference between selling for someone
else and selling your own idea
there are around 16 million salespeople
and most of them sell a product or
service that isn't of their own making
when a prospect isn't interested in the
product or service or doesn't choose
their company it's not personal it's not
about them it's simply a part of selling
however when a prospect isn't interested
in your product or service or doesn't
choose your company well now it is
personal most entrepreneurs are unable
to separate themselves from their
business's products and services and
that makes it difficult for them to ask
tough questions push back and ask for
the business they can't handle being
rejected number two this is different -
back when you attempted to convince your
friends family members and potential
employees that your business had legs
and could succeed you were very
persuasive they bought in hook line &
sinker but now when you attempt to get
prospects to pay for your product or
service it's a completely different
story money is involved your prospect
must not only like your product or
service better than the alternative but
they must also believe that the price
you set is fair and provides value some
entrepreneurs are very uncomfortable
defending their value and having it the
discussion about money 3 this is very
different perhaps the biggest challenge
for most entrepreneurs is the
realization that this isn't like the
movies in Field of Dreams Kevin
Costner's character hears and acts on
the voice that says build it and they
will come so you build it but they don't
come you market it but that generates
some crappy leads after struggling to
generate revenue for longer than the
plan called for you finally come to the
realization that you must sell
unfortunately for you selling means
getting on the phone and making calls
cold calls and you never signed up for
that so now you're having call anxiety
you find anything and everything else
that you could possibly do instead of
making those dreaded calls and of course
no calls means no no no new
opportunities on those rare occasions
when you can motivate or force yourself
to make calls you aren't very good at
them few people will talk with you and
even fewer interested once in a while
you succeed it's scheduling a call or
meeting and there are so few of those
and so much pressure to close that
you're afraid to say or do anything that
would jeopardize the opportunity the
result is that you simply aren't very
good at this so what can an entrepreneur
like you do when you have a great
business or product idea but little
desire or ability to sell here are some
options have yourself evaluated for
selling an evaluation will help you
understand exactly why you're struggling
which weaknesses are getting in the way
which skills are missing and whether or
not it's realistic for you to improve
objective Management Group has an
entrepreneurial sales evaluation that
addresses this very issue training and
coaching assuming that there's hope for
you in sales some top-notch training and
coaching will get you bringing in the
business more effectively more quickly
and more frequently hire a sales person
most entrepreneurs haven't hired people
before and hiring salespeople is
challenging even for those with
experience it's best to get help because
you can't afford to make a mistake on
your first key sales higher objective
Management Group has a sales candidate
assessment that helps with selection but
you want some advice to help with
setting up a proper sales recruiting
process to
outsource there are several outsourcing
options you can look into
there's call technology connect and sell
comm will automate the dialing so you
can spend your limited time actually
speaking with contacts you can have as
many conversations as an hour as you
would normally have in a week
appointment setting Green leads comm
will make the calls and schedule first
meetings on your behalf
independent reps rep hundred net will
allow you to search for $10.99
commission only reps that will sell for
you if you're an entrepreneur that needs
to significantly increase revenue and do
it quickly stop beating your head
against the wall and feeling like a
failure stop hoping that tomorrow
someone will call and place a huge order
stop believing that your outstanding
proposals will close take action get
some help and focus on what you do best
improving your business products and
services